thoughts before magnus played but what  magnus played the next move okay too i  mean  this is  this isn't approved by the computer  this is did he just bishop oh my god  yes  look at him he just  he just blundered  he just blundered he went tight c5 and  missed a bishop takes a2  and look at him laughing it off he's  just saying while it happens what to do  he clearly missed that there was a  bishop all the way back at g8  believable  he just showed that  the world champion is apparently human  yeah and look at this now he's using  bishop takes a6 out of desperation yeah  he could have just done it with the rook  on a1 and win the game and instead now  he has to do it do it out of desperation  now black is a full rook up yeah black  is a full